sadly as you know we lost uh joan rivers
last week and i know that you knew joan
rivers very well you worked with her
uh in the movie space balls and uh
i was just curious to get your your take
on maybe what was
her greatest attribute you think as a
comedian she was sharp
she was really bright really funny and
very dangerous
she'd go into like unknown territory
and take her chances with saying
that's not a dress that's a rug i mean
she would say things that were
horrible terrible wonderfully funny she
was very brave she was
always courageous and
off camera she was the nicest sweetest
dearest person and you know and
i loved her and you know and together
with
two geniuses so soon robin williams
and and joan river i mean two really
as close to genius as you can get uh in
their own
game you know well you know it's it's a
it's fascinating to me that
we now live in an era where it feels
like everything is supposedly edgy
but so many i'm going to tell you if i
die there'll be no more show business
i think that'll be the end of the wait
you're it
after you there's no more show business
i don't know i've been coughing in the
dressing
you room to stay alive because i got a
mortgage
yeah is that a german name is that
germany
germany
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right you subbed
for joan rivers on her show oh yeah she
could not
uh host her show one night when she had
a late night talk show and you said she
asked me to come up
to be her host so i took over the joan
river show for one night
and it's quite interesting you took a
big chance but i think it worked out
let's take a look at that okay let's
take a clip of me
all right i was lucky i went backstage i
looked around for
a joan rivers dress and i saw this
beauty on the rack that she forgot to
take i grabbed it i put it on
and i tell you it's comfortable
i mean i've been dressing i've been
dressing like a guy all my life
i mean you cross your legs with jackie
shorts with zippers i mean it's hard you
know
i mean this is the pleasure i gotta tell
you
i mean this is terrific and you want to
know something the best thing about it
is that you get
air under here